for those who haven't already seen um
we're going to be spending
uh up to three days hopefully um
together
there's a reserved time of friday but
we're um i i doubt
well fingers crossed uh we won't be
requiring that but
looking forward to your company over the
next few days as we
talk about uh our long-term plan so
firstly apologies uh any
any conflicts of interest for anyone
anyone wishes to care
counts about it uh just mr me will we
declare them as we go through each
report like we normally do yes that's
fine unless you've got you want to
declare them in advance that's
totally fine whichever you prefer which
we've felt it
you all right okay
um so just firstly um
there's a couple of additional agenda
items
um around particularly the rengar civic
precinct so i just need to
i'd like to move that we consider that
additional report that's been circulated
um that we consider the additional
reporters listed
it was one of the diligent report it's
intelligent it's one of the
uh appended diligent report well the
only additional report
yeah so moved for council of violence
seconded by
councillor duty any discussion all in
favor i
contrary to clear that carriage okay so
uh we now come to the overview and
financial strategies so
jim and jeff perhaps if i thank you mr
mayor perhaps if i could just start with
some introductory comments and then jeff
as you're familiar with will give you
the
the overview and a little more detail
about our position
so a little bit about the running of the
three uh
of the three days um
and sarah's already given you some
advice we
uh when we we'll be working off
both the diligent reports and i see all
of you have bought your folders which is
probably the best
way of working through the budgets
rather than the electronic version i
would imagine
in the past and i think it would be a
good thing for you to consider today
is for each of the budget areas
we've traditionally adopted those pro
forma
which saves us having to move and second
and debate every particular
section of the budget that doesn't
though preclude you from
moving an amendment to any of the
budgets and if you wanted to move an
amendment
our custom and practice has been to
treat that amendment
as though it were a motion which enables
that person to have the
right of reply should they want to
change anything in the budget
when we get to them the diligent reports
though they would be treated as we treat
any normal
agenda report which has moved seconded
and debated as we would do on any other
day
so hopefully that is
understood and clear
the timings you know we're here for as
long as we need to be here
there is a request for
simon markham's budgets to be considered
later in the day
as he's needs to be in wellington for
the next couple of days so from about 3
30 wherever we get to at about 3 30
his team's budgets will be considered at
that point
uh i have an apology from about four
o'clock today i've got greater
christchurch
partnership chief executive meeting and
it's got a number of
important matters on it and jeff is
going to write a shotgun
for the mayor if needed so that will
happen later
in the day in terms of the
draft budget that you have in front of
you
we have put that together based on the
numerous
meetings and workshops we've had
discussing
our approach and we think we've landed
with something which
was our understanding of the signals we
got from council
over the last four or five months in
particular so hopefully
most of it aligns with your
understanding of course there's
opportunities for debate and that's what
today's all about
we have got together a draft
the draft words of the consultation
document
and we thought that would be useful to
circulate to you
soon in the next so that you can see the
flavor of that and you can see where the
issues that we're talking about how
we've captured those
and if you've got any feedback for us
about that then we'd be happy to receive
that so
i understand that's being um
going to be in hard copy to it
oh put it on
oh okay they're gonna make it look oh
okay they're gonna make it look
a little flash of for us so
we'll let you know when that's there but
over the probably by the time we've got
to day three it would be good in the
wrap-up conversation to say based on
everything
does this look and feel about what right
and what you were expecting from the
conversation
i think
that that's all of the key comments
happy to answer any questions on
anything i've said otherwise i've passed
to jeff
to start the overview any initial
questions of john
i just want to give some feedback i
think of all the years
i've been i've had the budget packs and
the
information here is excellent so thanks
to the staff for the week
it's been a huge piece of work preparing
all this but just in advance to say
and i know there's been a range of
questions from colleagues which has been
really good
i like how it's been looked after this
year sarah so we all
get an idea and a flavor of what the
questions are that's not to stop
questions here today because that's
entirely what the process is about but
it has given us
a better ability um to see what the
answers are and thanks to chief and the
team
and all that have been involved in
providing the answers to that
any questions team one last thing i
forgot was
um scheduled breaks there's half an hour
lunch and i think 12 45 is the intended
lunch break
and that um
spring room uh is available in the green
room which is down the end of the
corridor and
uh and far right it looks green funny
enough
and we're here the intention is to be
here till about
six each day um so hopefully that means
that maybe thursday doesn't go quite as
long
and if it does well we'll have needed
all of that time
um so morning tea and the afternoon tea
breaks about 10 15
and 3 15. i'm going to try to stick to
those times because it's important we
have those um stops so just to give it's
so 12 45 for lunch
um today all right
thanks jeff thank you so good morning
i'm here in councillors uh this will be
our sixth ltp since 2006.
we do every three years and i think
from my perspective it's been one which
have had
more staff briefings and brilliant uh
direction from the council
in making uh the documentation provided
to
today the quality that it is i think i
think it is
i agree with your comments uh mr mia it
was it's
very good uh so
um i think the key
twisting and turning here so
just a reminder of the key documents
that go into the
ltp and consultation process
it's quite clever
the key section of the main document
itself has
the mirror's message and overview so it
has good overview of what's
actually happening not over one year but
10 years
unlike other annual plans this document
will have
a financial strategy and an
infrastructure strategy
that gets put into the front of the
document
some councils use standalone ones we put
ours in the one document that makes the
document we feel it makes the document
flow better
and unlike the mandatory requirement of
30 years we do our
infrastructural strategy over 150 years
basically try and take the fuller life
of the assets
and the reason for that is it means our
depreciation policy which
i'll just explain a little bit later on
then there's the activity statements
and there's mandatory ones and other
mandatory ones so
they are included within the year of
each of their little commentaries
and budgets that extend over the 10-year
period not just the
year period and comparison to the
previous year
so we have a rates impact statement and
[Music]
and in the consultation document itself
the consultation document has to be a
standalone document
and it's not a summary of the main
document it actually
the reason standalone is it has a number
of options in there
which we are consulting the community on
and we'll just explain those
a bit later
that consultation document goes under a
hop review
and what they do is they measure our
consultation document and the
information it has in it and see whether
it's standard and has the information
as other councils should across the
country
website will prove all the information
on the website so about background
material that will go on the website
and uh
the underlying policies amps
and strategies and assumptions
at the moment you've been provided with
the draft
consultation plan and i understand the
list is just finalizing the more
detailed one
that allows councillors to commit to the
presentation of their different venues
around the district over the next
six six weeks when it's consulted
uh so this is just coming one
at a time so this is the whole lot there
um the
assumptions and policies so over the
last
three or four months or more we've been
going through
the key assumptions we've looked at
a number of the economic factors finance
revenue financing policy
which is a paper later on to make a
small change to that
rating policies uh doing some amendments
which will make that work better for our
community
treasury policy depreciation funding
we've looked at it again
and we've updated the development
contributions and the underlying amps
and level of service
that we're providing uh just one note
the ltp has been current
current it's like in other years it's
been produced in a form which
sees the council as a going concern
controlling the assets of three waters
just to put that confirm that the basis
of that we've we've done it is that
we're still managing that asset and
we're still providing
water and soil supply
so the growth assumptions that we've
used in the
ltp much the same as what we
used in the current three periods areas
and that's that we're projecting on a
medium to high
growth based on new zealand's stats
figures
and so that seizes for a population of
about
seventy eight thousand four hundred and
ninety two thousand thirty one
and just looking at that line here
that's that red line that
goes through there it says
the rationale for that is we're
continuing to grow
above the the rate which is
set on the medium figures
i'm sorry councilman what's the latest
date of census figures that we've
received on that jeff
and do you know when the latest one is
due out yeah i think
that is the the problem i don't think we
have this and the latest i think this is
based
on the previous one which is
extrapolated out
yeah so we still don't have 2018 census
data completely but
with the the latest population
estimate we have for the district which
was june last year is
sixty four thousand seven or eight
hundred i think
seven hundred that is then is the
current
estimated population thirty june 2020
so we're extrapolating from the 2013
figures
is that correct i think stats
numbers are a composite somewhere of a
composite
2013 plus what they've seen what they
estimate
since that time so it's a it's a
polite would be a hybrid type
position it's the best data that we can
find at the moment
and if it's materially different when we
get an update well
we'll look at what the implications are
but yeah it's
it's not ideal but it's what we've got
so what that means is we're we're
growing about 4
800 new dwellings over that period of
time
uh the year that we're in currently
we're projecting uh based on 550 new
dwellings in the
2021-22 year and of course we have to
model it out
so it equals that 4800 over the period
of time so it drops away
uh last time we consulted
mainly on five main topics this time
just the three but those five main
topics are still having impacts on
rates in the current ltp
such as the multi-sports facility which
is completed
later this year so the three three sub
the three topics that we are focusing on
are mainly strategic
focused and there's a number of papers
which
cover those later on in the budgets the
first one is the community facilities at
pegasus and wood end
in the ravenswood area to secure the
land there for
future development of community
facilities
the second one is to expand uh and
upgrade the
treatment trevor inch memorial
library and couple that with the
rangiora civic center
just makes sense to bring those two
projects together uh
leaving the civic center where it was
in year 11 which is now year eight in
the next ltp
and coupling the library with that and
the third one was provision of car park
building facilities in the rengar town
centre
in year eight of the ltp
we're covering although the other
specific options that we're
seeking feedback on we're covering in
the cd document other topics as well
which the public would like to give
feedback on and that's updating
a covered response and recovery plan
responding to climate change and system
sustainability
and also making sure that the public are
aware of the
government's initiative for three ward
infrastructure
reviews there's some other areas which
we're providing more substantial updates
on that's the district plan
when that's um being consulted
the western uh rangor and road
improvements
in the waste water pipeline capacity
upgrades for the eastern districts
saw and storm water
waterway upgrades so you'll see that
we're
very much a going concern with the three
waters there's
quite a significant program being
knocked out
on the climate change um
would we not be showing that in a
separate
given it's an unknown for everybody um
including us would we not be showing
that as a separate topic topic so there
would be four main
major consultations i mean that is
something in the next 10 years which is
going to be
going to be the forefront of this
council if you like or any council
would we not be better at to extrapolate
that out i mean obviously
um emphasize the unknown
factor of it but just my view i think it
needs to be a
number four or number three maybe number
one in the thing if you're going to try
it out
prioritising a bit separate so i think
it's intended for
what is the fourth bullet point down
covert response responding to climate
change and sustainability and government
infrastructure review each of those to
have a separate section which shows
shows them clearly that the challenge
we've
had with that group of issues they're
all significant issues
but in terms of our engagement
we don't really have any material
options
to engage on you know it's a bit
left to say we do it or we don't do it
well
of course we're going to and we don't
have enough yet around say climate
change
to say here's the major proposal
which materially affects but we
certainly want to give
air time to those issues explain that
they are
being reflected in our in our document
and this is our approach and
in some cases they're a watching brief
and in the case of three waters review
of that materializes
it could see a fundamental rethink and
probably an amendment or a new ltp
depending on the consultation and
engagement required around those so
in our heart of hearts we didn't want to
include
clayton options for consultation on
topics that
you know there isn't really a we're
welcome to receive feedback like we have
whereas the first three issues we've put
in
you know some some alternate options
which
are plausible particularly around the
timing
of those first three issues
there is that don't do it at all option
of course but
the others usually involve changing the
timing
of those projects as they're currently
sitting in their plan i suppose what i'm
asking is exactly your explanation is
actually in that document
is what i'm saying the unknowns and the
reasons why as opposed to
what we're doing because we're not there
yeah and
and hopefully when you've had a chance
to have a look at the document be
interested in your feedback as to
whether
that flavor is about right or not
just just to remind sorry so i'll just
just add to that
um so everything that's in the in the
annual
ltps up for debate and comment from the
community
these are just the strategic ones that
cover that and just a reminder
to actually put an option out there
it needs to have basically three things
one you have to identify what the issue
is
you have to identify what the options
are that you're considering
and cost and the last one is that you
have to actually indicate what the
impact
on the rate payer is and
so with those it's very difficult to
determine that with a climate change
policy
yeah that's the clarity that's exactly
what i'm saying we need explained in
there
why we don't have those three things as
the unsure is around if our community
understands that hopefully they will
still come and
submit to us on how they see the world
but
that's exactly the explanation that i'm
talking about thanks to
casablanca yes jeff totally understand
that
these are um issues that basically they
cut they affect everybody pretty much
they're quite
um high-reaching and strategic as you
say however we do have a fees in charge
quite a substantial fees and charge
change
at the airfield which the report says
has not been consulted yet with
the wider community that's been wrapped
into the budget how is that going to be
consulted on
with the users of the airfield is that
going to
have a section of any sort to highlight
that to users of the ear field
um i think perhaps that would be a good
one to talk about when we get to
consider that matter
and whether there is a more targeted
engagement and sometimes in the past we
have had
targeted engagements that run parallel
and if
the council feels that's warranted uh
with
a select group then that can that can be
something we can do then
definitely thank you thanks jim so
coming to the next one which is probably
the key one you want to look at is
what are the rate impacts over the next
10 years
we've done a little bit of smoothing not
a lot of moving goes into year one
and the reason for that is uh
a lot of the large capital program is in
the front
year or two which has an impact it
spreads out
and on rates in the following years in
terms of
the additional cost and depreciation
that it comes with
so two three point nines in the first
two years
uh followed by uh four four point twos
and then it drops down to what
the next slide i'll just explain how
that's how it's all working in terms of
inflation but just to explain
how we sort of in a general sense how we
get to those numbers
is if you take the local government cost
index which is based
on the bill inflation adjusters
they range between zero point uh
negative zero point six percent in the
current year we're in
3.6 in the first year but if you look at
those numbers across the 10 years they
average out around about 2.6 percent
so we all are projecting local
government
cost inflation particularly from a
roundabout year three four right through
of 2.5 and 2.6
if you look at the putting the
progressive earthquake funding which
stops
uh increasing in year nine of the ltp
uh add that to that number you get
around about 3.5
to 4.5 and that's what we're
averaging if you look at our 20
last 20 years of rate increases they
average it 4.3
uh some comments
in terms of what other councils are
doing i'm not seeing anything
that's lower than these numbers
i think the the year of the 1.5 percent
and covert is certainly impacting a
little bit on
how we're predicting some of the figures
so these numbers contain all of the
reports that are
for decision uh in front of the council
but they do exclude the
opt-in for curbside collection curbside
waste collection they include the
recycling
collection numbers
if you look at the the way
inflation works is you hit the cp
[Music]
the green line that comes through here
is the these are based on girl again
cpi is coming through on the green line
for the 10 years
you see the local government cost
index so we're using that average of the
two
in year one it pops up here
to 2.9 and comes out here
so there's a fair bit of fluctuation
around in this period here
the blue line at the top here is our
rate projections
and if you were to take off the
earthquake funding
you see that coming quite close to the
local government cost index at the end
of that
eight year eight to ten line
so we're trying to keep
increases in those outer years quite
close to that
inflation not a lot we can do
in this period here we have quite a lot
of capex program
that's impacting through there and um
and i've already pre-circulated the
capital program that's out there
um 85 million in the current year 70
million
million in year one and although some of
that's been
funded from external
shovel ready and stimulus funding is
still impacting on the rate
if you look at the individual area
increases
based on this is based on the average
property
this year what that property would pay
in the first year of the ltp the figures
are looking
uh not too bad
that's cheap beer is showing
properties with average movements some
of those ones there
such as burnside they have that
the joining of the scheme so that's and
that includes the
uh the loan uh repayment over that
25-year period uh
second sheet you see some of the urban
areas such as rangiora
and kaiapoi a lot of the urban areas
around that
3.74
points right down the bottom here once
again that's part of that
pre-consulted rate which that
community's been
advised on
uh operating expenditure
uh so the green line here is
is rates and the orange line is over
that little lip there is some of the
funding that we're getting
for grant funding
it's more affected by the the roading
program so that spreading subsidies
coming through here
but you see rates over that period of
time they're going to increase 73
uh 49 million
and our expenditure uh is 38
uh or 40 million uh the difference
between the two
of them is the progressive funding and
the loan repayment provisions that we
are making so if you look think about
the earthquake lane
uh funding that goes from three million
dollars
and you won up to about 10 million
in year 10. and i just thought for
interest i'd
show the proportions that we're
budgeting
for uh interest really
does rise they're consistent in
maintenance and operational work as
opposed to
depreciation and
personnel costs like that
round the wrong way sorry that's our
personal costs and that's our
interest
so what they normally report in the
in the papers is that we've got this
huge rate increase
but you've got to remember that's
inflation uh
proofed and
you know some of the true increases that
that come through don't
they're not really they reflect that but
it's it's inflation so if you think
about
property prices and what they go up in
10 years
you can sort of make that comparison
but pretty consistent expenditure
no real big flops coming through
and that that graph here sorry table
watch out chart is just showing
uh where the operational expenditure is
occurring so you can see that rotting
and
recreation are two biggest individual
activities
uh recreation making up of you know
green space and
buildings and facilities of course
[Music]
the three waters around here making up
about 20
to 25 of our business
that's our building control and
environmental services
just to explain the the capex so
when you look at the capex program it
looks like we've got
quite a large program that pushed out to
the end
it's it's not quite like that
the blue is the inflated capex
and the orange is
the uninflated capex so you can see out
here
[Music]
it's it's pretty standard
but just to explain that there are
four key projects which come into that
and that's what i've tried to negate out
here
so except for these four major project
projects the library civic center
screw bridge and some roading
in relation to the parking tram road and
the western
side of the bypass that takes you around
that route
a capital program is pretty consistent
when you take the inflation out of that
so we come down from you know take for
instance in the near
22 23 39 39 out here 36
capital expenditure by category um
once again it's fairly fairly consistent
you've got some additional
demand that's coming in here in terms of
some of the silver and
projects out here the library
in civic center the green here
is our new levels of service
trouble ready and stimulus funding
that's coming through additional
when we talk about the three categories
it's not
a pure sense like that uh you have to
like there's some works there that'll
have a bit of both i have renewal
capital
and um sorry growth and renewals
um you put it the rule is is that
you put it into the one that has the
most amount of
[Music]
of that nature of capital unless you can
easily separate it
so what is that doing to det
but it's pretty well consistent with
what we were saying
in the last ltp
uh we are
increasing in this period here so you
can see the red
is our new debt uh green is our
repayment of debt and the blue line here
is our total accumulated debt
so you can see it's slowly rising in
terms of the new loans
and here we're starting to pay off more
debt than than loans and we start
dropping down
and this part here this is the library
civic centre some of that capital
working went through there
which pushes it up if you go a little
bit further out from there
into year 20 it drops down again so
state starts coming down
i think the key thing that i always look
at in terms of
debt in terms of credit rating
is trying to keep that debt under 180
percent of the ratio so
deep to total revenue extremes
uh standard and pause they they work at
that figure a little bit different to
the way we work it out but
the key thing for us is to make sure we
keep that deep
under 180. you can see down the bottom
here
quite high at the moment and is right
they they signaled to us that
they were getting concerned but then
they took that off
the negative rating office and made it
stable
and you can see from here
the 176 180 176 and it's slowly
rapidly well directly through here
decreases to 142 we're in a good
position
so in terms of our credit rating we
should
be able to maintain a double a
stable on those numbers
if you look at that graphically as well
and this one here is actually showing
our policy we keep headroom for
if we've got insurance and haven't got
insurance so these are the
orange and blue here so that little cap
on the top there is our headroom which
we
we kept ourselves with i should note
that
we've just got to update this this table
here
that line that's straight there now
pops up to uh close to the 300
and then drops away slowly under the
local government funding agency
what we're doing is we're trying to make
sure we
stay within that policy our own internal
policy
as well if you look at
interested total rates
um looks pretty good well under that
policy limit
and um it's been maintained pretty
consistent as you would expect
with that total depth the profile we
showed before
it's worth explaining the depreciation
policy and our future renewals
so
our current policy for depreciation is
that we we don't fully depreciate the
actual cost of depreciation
but we do take that into account when we
actually extrapolate
the depreciation itself and the
investment curve
so what we do is we set our appreciation
at levels
which will be able to renew the asset
when it comes up
renewal uh also taking account the
investment that we get off those funds
so not only will we be a borrower but
we're an investor in 80 years
so just explaining the graph here these
are all the different activities that we
have in the renewal profiles so that
bottom one there is our roading which
you expect is quite consistent
the little bit here would be
some of our maybe some of our major
bridge revenue or cold
meal three waters
[Music]
comes through here and green space
and some of us here is more of our
buildings
so you can see the red line here is yeah
accumulated depreciation and we're
building up a fund
and this is net of any renewals that
take place
so in this year we would pay out that
much this would be a
amount of renewals accumulated funds
that would be left to for future renewal
so that grows up here to such levels
where it's able to maintain this high
growth
of renewal program through here you see
that sustained through here high capital
cost of renewals
that fund drops away right down to here
and it's maintained down here and you
would expect this comes down
and that grows back up again that's over
years
for the first time in the annual report
this year we
we actually reported on that and some
people did pick up on it
that we uh and and questioned how that
was working they quite liked the model
um but what that's telling what that
shows and communicates to the public is
that
we're prudently managing that renewals
program
over the whole life of the asset we're
not just looking at 30 years
if you're just to look at 30 years we
would come in here
and we'd think oh we're okay you don't
have to build that fund up
once you got to here you'd have to have
substantial loan programs
which would be it's not
intergenerational equity
it would be quite remiss on us not to
actually build this fund up
because of this high sustained growth
that we've gone through the last 25
years
so it's quite an important piece of
our strategy and our engine
the whole council where engineers
planners and
recreation green space team are all
bought into this
and they all use this as part of the
asset management planning
so um cost drivers
so we've got the earthquake increase we
know that's that's heading
511 000 in year one and that's going to
continuously
add between 0.7 and 1 of
our total rates until we hit that
threshold where it's able to be
rate repaying the power for the debt
rate for
earthquakes uh capex program
so you can see the 85 million here um 71
million
year one yeah our normal capital works
programs it's like somewhere between
uh that slide we showed before about 30
million and 40
million per annum
the multi-use stadium so that opens
some time after around july august and
that rate and starts
you know the cost for the loan funding
and that's starting to kick in near as
well
in the shop already in stimulus 27
million
although most of that's funded we still
had was taking out some
50 of the shovel ready to meet that
funding
bringing forward some of the program
that was there
and the cost of the
maintaining that network and
depreciation kicks in a little bit
earlier
so that's why the smoothing of the rate
is quite important to actually these
large spikes
if you look at the dollar increase with
where they've been
you can see that
[Music]
they're pretty well right across the
board really quite even
evenly spread
3.9 percent uh
no real large
increases from some of the areas there
and you can see that well this table
here where we look at the
movements by activity i suppose the
largest one here is the earthquake
510 22 increase in that rate
so um sometimes it's not just the dollar
increase here that you have to look at
it's actually the percentage
increase that you're looking at
that's the key thing and they are
unadjusted for growth
roading here at four percent uh that's
the large capex
program so that's why you're not seeing
that coming through
uh generate movements and that's just
highlighting the fact that
it's mainly made up of general
earthquake and that's the all the
general rate activity and you can see
there
there's uh there's quite significant
increases
going down to negative increases the top
one there is the code funding you reduce
that
loan funding from two million to one
million
all proposing to and just a
wagon wheel showing that just showing
the same but
as a proportion
uh i thought i'd just cover the other uh
adjustments that we've made in line with
policy
so we've done some minor adjustments for
revenue financing policy uh the one the
two that we need to make adjustments for
uh and there's no significant impacts on
properties but there's the uniform
annual general charge that's gone from
1.2135
this is not a 15 increase on urban
properties because
uh the general rate is a combination of
land uh sorry
capital value and fixed price so the
actual effect is
of that fifteen dollars is a four
dollars a four dollar increase to the
average property
uh and the same effect for the
recreation uh legal service to the
neighborhood communities
that's gone to 85 we haven't adjusted
that for a number of years
uh the effect of oh sorry
let's just before you is anyone else
feeling a little
chilly yeah so we could i know it's
going to be a warm day but perhaps we
just adjusted a little i'm feeling a bit
freezing down
[Laughter]
a lot of numbers here but um and the
effect of that is seven dollar
movement on a on a sort of a property
it's worth about 3100
so not a lot of movement uh just minor
adjustments
uh but they do have big bigger impacts
to the larger
you know farm properties and so forth
yes just just to remind people in our
recreation rate
we have two rates one for one for our
urban areas and one for our
residential and residential areas pay
and we're proposing pay an extra 85 over
rural and that pays for all of the
neighborhood
reserves and higher amenity that sits
within our urban areas
uh and then the important one which
we're not allowed to breach
is that you don't have any more than
30 of these types of uniform charges
across the district uh
that cap we are sitting at 25 at the
moment so we're well in that cap
the largest it gives to is the near
eight of the ltp
and that gets to 27.49 so well within
those
oh
there we go
so um happy to take any uh questions
that's uh thanks jeff
thanks for that overview any questions
from colleagues
i think you've done a good job of
explaining all right they'll get a copy
of uh members will get a copy of this in
diligent as well
is that where you intend to provide it
yeah a copy of this and a copy of the cd
document diligently
great thanks sarah phil you the question
just one question jeff the the rate
projections are they based on
extending some of the loan repayment
terms
or is that separate from what you've
given us
all all the papers that are in front of
the council included in these numbers so
whatever decisions you make
that are against those recommendations
i'll have to back out
of this and then represent present that
to you
the paper that jeff's bringing that
you're going to consider shortly about
taking a longer term on our loan
repayments
if you resorted to the status quo
we would add um it would take seven
million off our debt but it would
raise some of our rate requirement in
each year if you were to retain the
status quo
so that's a conversation to be had
jeff's numbers anticipate you
uh supporting what he's proposing now if
you don't you'll have to unwind that
that's right
crystal ball gazing jeff um ashburton
ashburton have just done a
um a project where they
looked at the the reduction in cost of
reduction to farming incomes of all the
water
things in the wider sense of all those
and all the plant changes
are enacted with the time frames that
they're putting
and they came up with an 80 reduction to
farming
incomes across the district um possibly
in our area be less than that because
we're probably not as dependent on
farming as ashburton
that have you factored in that sort of
doomsday
scenario or in your business
you know as well as just explain you've
got to work on a business as usual
but but are some of those factors if you
you've got to comment on that sort of
thing coming to bite us in the next
12 24 months i'm not sure of ashburton's
circumstances they um
i'm not sure if they'll have rate
increases lies either because they've
got a
large 55 million
these these uh
are not factoring in those incomes no
but what
what it does do with the real numbers is
that it brings in
what the effects are to us
we we probably we have about 15 percent
of our rate powers that
that are eligible for the rate uh
a rebate so quite conscious that
um
trying to keep those figures quite close
to that local government cost index i
should say that the
local government cost index is included
in the cpi
so even though we're above that for our
sector
those numbers are included in the whole
wash of things so
that rates are considered as part of the
um as the cpi movement
just further to that i think in in
ashburton in the report you refer to as
the effect of um national policy
statement on freshwater
if and the higher standards that align
with that and
it anticipates that will affect farm
gate revenue which
directly is going to flow through to
farm valuation
for them as for us those effects are
going to roll through
in revaluations over time and if
they they may well revert to their next
highest alternate use to their current
use now
whether that's subdivision or whether
that's some alternate farming
value use which generates a lower value
that will then reflect through in our
total valuation
and will progressively hit the qv
estimate of the value of our district
and
what that will do is impact the
incidence of
rating so that if those property values
were to plummet
as a result of that and obviously that
causes
significant hardship along the way with
that
then the council i think at that time if
there were
major changes in the incidence of rating
and the fairness of that then the
council would want to reflect on its
revenue and finance policy
and its rating settings at that time
to respond to that it might also
ultimately impact council's view on
levels of service although that's
too early to for shadow at this time
so there you are right to highlight that
there is uncertainty
facing all communities in new zealand
particularly
um we're going to face some uncertainty
in our urban
communities to address some of those
issues as well
so they will put pressures on all parts
of our community and how we respond as a
council we
it is one of the things we're going to
have to carefully consider
probably it will kick in may kick in by
the time of the next revaluation
maybe depending on the progress starting
this
we're in a weird property market space
at the moment and
but there is some softening and farm
values given that uncertainty that's
sitting out there so
you're right to note it but at this time
it's too early for us to to other than
note that that is a
that is an issue it's too early for us
to be able to effectively assess the
impact of that across our district
probably something we're going to have
to model quite a bit
at the next revaluation if there's a
significant dip or at our next ltp
if some of those implications start
become clearer then that'll start a
conversation on revenue
and financing policy yeah
sorry i missed their point um
you're going to see some silly numbers
come out in the cell tp i think
across the sector and it depends on each
council's circumstances as well
it is important to note that these
numbers do not include any proposed
movement of
ecan rates on our repairs so these are
waimakariri district only
increases and we understand that
the increases proposed by ecan could be
significantly more than what we're
signing
so that because they sit on our rate
invoice
we may get a little bit of collateral
with that
and we will need to explain clearly the
difference if that is the case
very clearly for example i i've only
seen one number under four percent
under five percent
only one so far under five and i've seen
quite a few
apart from us um but it's once again
it depends on the circumstances what
they've got in play and
the revenue financing policy is another
thing that we just identified
um we we do it purely on land value our
capital value some councils are still on
land valley
um has different impacts among the rate
that's we've got a number of
differentials which
we identify different levels of service
so um they'll have their own pressures
and uh
it might spark a favor the debate
through the sector
we know i think we're going to go into a
little bit of a period
it's a huge uncertainty this this ltp is
probably the most uncertain one
we haven't the environment around us is
impacting
uh we've got climate change
sustainability we've got covered we
don't know whether there'll be another
lockdown for instance we have a lockdown
what does that do
to our rates and
you know you're hearing economists say
some are saying that there's going to be
interest rate movements uh in 80 months
time upwards
uh you still get a commerce saying
there's going to be a higher
unemployment
in the second quarter of uh this year
so there's there's lots of things to
consider
we just have to put a responsible budget
out here
windy
we're a bit concerned about this
earthquake
depth we've got and because that really
could be a big
milestone around our neck and um just
think that we need to
get that under control because we have
no idea
you're saying it's going out now to year
nine which has been stretched out
just really concerned about the what
we're actually going to be
inflicting on our other rate payers
yeah so it's a good point and it's a
strategy that we put in place a number
of years ago and we've added to
regeneration um and that's what's
always been pushed out a little bit it's
still within that uh
25-year repayment period so we're still
keeping
to our promise to have that all paid off
within the 25 years
it does end up like a small rate at um
from memory it peaks around about 395
dollars thereabouts
and year team with inflation
but yeah it's it's uh
i suppose it's one of those little
legacies that you have from an
earthquake
if when everyone strikes us we just need
to make sure
that we've got a head room there to make
sure we can battle through that one as
well
the the alternative there's really only
one alternative strategy which is um
is to accelerate
the repayment and accelerate the
the rate so ask for more
rates sooner is the is the only other
option
given given everything that's at play in
play
um we've we've still think supporting
the current approach is the right
approach the alternate would be to
seek more from our rate payers earlier
and
get that rate level higher earlier than
what
is currently forecast and i'm not
sensing a great desire to want to do
that
you'll see some councils do that though
they'll have a big rate
sort of 10 11 and uh straight
but it sits at 10 11 for a long time
um whereas ours what we're trying to do
is cushion those rates out smooth them
down keep them low as possible
and because we're dealing with long-term
assets
um people in the next 50 years
to 70 years will still be enjoying those
assets without paying for them
so i'm quite comfortable
you know trying to stretch that out
knowing that those assets will be there
for a number of years
if you have questions
all right thank you jeff thanks jim
sarah if we
had an early morning team this makes
sense to start
uh jared's section is that going to be
okay
we started the bit
there's a report first should we deal
with that yes oh there's a performer
recommendation first actually so
um okay let's deal with those
good good plan so firstly um
just tear everyone's attention thank you
um
normally as a matter of course we'll
have a um performer recommendation that
just
adopts and confirms all the budget
recommendations we
that doesn't mean that we don't come
back and look at that differently later
that would just be treated as a simple
amendment as we go through
so counselor um meetings
is moving seconded by council ward
that the council adopt and confirm all
budget resolutions as pro forma
i think what you're happy to make any
discussion
i'll put that all those in favor all
right
contrary to clear that carried so we
come to now
4.1
which is in your um and your
agenda managing that reports
one just on process one thing i didn't
mention which is what we've
traditionally done there are reports
in diligent as that relate to each
area what we propose to do is we deal
with those when we get
to it so for when we get to roading if
there's a roading related report we do
that first and then we go to the
detailed budgets
after that there are two reports that we
want to deal with at the earliest
opportunity they make sense in coming up
in the discussion
and under roading we would like to deal
with the whole
town centre's car parking report
which is uh 4.6
i think it is we want to deal with that
at the first instance
so that the roading that's the first
time it intersects with our conversation
and then we get that all locked in
so that's one that we want to do early
and the other one that we're going to do
early
is the civic center
library and we propose to do that as
part of the library conversation
rather than the property conversation
which happens right at the last
on the last day if you or the last hour
of the last day so
we'll do like we'll do the civic library
one
as part of the library debate
thank you okay
thank you so oh
don't have time david
oh sorry very glum
yes don't interpret that that's where
happy is going david
um thank you um so jeff if we could now
deal with uh 4.1 so that's in the
um budget packs as in the um
diligently so it's proposed change to
treasury policy thank you
uh this does make a change to the treaty
policy by increasing the
term in the land from 25 to 50 years uh
suggesting we do this with three waters
infrastructure
and also suggest that we look at that
for other
areas as well uh
the rationale for this is that
it provides a good
[Music]
relationship to enter general rational
generational equity um
a lot of the assets that we have um
that we're purchasing the weighted
average life of those assets is beyond
that
period so therefore
it's come about because we're looking at
basically
how do we reduce rates and how do we
improve the way we do things i had a
good look around
some councils and some do extend their
funding out as far as this
um when you look at a number of the
assets that you were using
where you could see this as being an
aggressive way
of funding those assets because they're
getting paid off and within 25 years
um and you some of these assets are
lasting 100
uh sorry 80 years plus
the other thing that you can sort of
related to is if you look at your home
ownership
you know you might have a home here
where you you buy into a new home
you put a lot the first person that buys
it puts it out for 25 years
they pay the loan off or they sell the
house and then another
owner comes in and goes out another 25
years you could have that same
property that has long too messy that's
getting funded by loan
over a long period of time
it it does help the rate power out the
current repair
it means that they don't pay as much in
rates you're not just looking at rate
payers and residential properties you're
looking at commercial business owners
it doesn't make a lot of
difference to some but a farmer for
instance that means that he has more
disposable income in his hand to
actually put into investment into his
property
and so the the next farmer that comes
along and farms that land yes he does
pay for some of those assets that he's
enjoying and the first farmer doesn't
uh so it's just using a farming
situation but you can
you can put a residential section or
anything into that mix and it's the same
philosophy
uh the differences uh remodeled is
is about 6.4 million
that we wouldn't be collecting in rates
over that 10 years
but and we'd be needing to offset that
with around about five
well similar funding and loan funding
so it does put the debt up uh there's a
graph in the
in the paper the table there that shows
that it
has minimal impact on our interest
policy the benchmark and indices we use
for that
and you can see in the middle of our
term here on the table 4.12 that
uh we don't get into a situation where
it just keeps on climbing and climbing
it's actually in proportion to uh
yeah number eight players and and what
our capital works program was at the
time so
happy to take any questions um yeah
i've just got one additional comment
which
i think i can make now um is that
this this sees a slight reduction in our
loan repayments on capital program
about 90 million of our debt
relates to three waters now
if the proposed reforms occur in the way
they're currently signaled
then we're hot we would anticipate that
that debt will go
with uh the assets and
that would be our expectation it's far
from clear
so the motivation to repay that debt
any faster than necessary at the moment
is low
on our base on our books so i'm just
gifts while we are
while we are wanting to ensure we're not
doing anything that's
inappropriate in terms of ensuring the
long-term
sustainability um this this
does would see that debt just sit
fractionally higher and
say three years time than it otherwise
would so
that will become the responsibility of
of a new infrastructure provider if that
was the way that this
um reform headed if yeah
and look at that point there'd probably
be a reef
a rethink about the overall strategy of
the remainder of the council business so
so that it's not a it's not a strong
driver but it's just something that's
set in the back of my mind as seeing
this is
not a not inappropriate not
irresponsible but not inappropriate to
do in the current environment
in addition to that too you've got to
remember also building up a replacement
fund
through depreciation at the same time so
you know
a 25-year loan on a long-term asset is
quite aggressive
so firstly councilman williams followed
by council reckons
at the moment um we're got a level of
quite low interest rates um
the next 25 years it's probably forklift
below
what happens in the scenario if all of a
sudden in
15 years time the interest rates
goes up to 20 like it's been before
how's that
going to affect our next generation of
people yeah it's a good question uh
what we have in place to try and
mitigate it is we have a treasury policy
and we keep our maturities in place with
that
on top of that we have interest rate
hedging which takes out the spikes
in those types of events and yes we
expect interest rates to start rising
again
and as we progress out we would issue
just for that but the key thing is that
we keep well within our
treasury policy limits and that is the
key to the
you know mitigating any risk here so
you're
telling me we can um keep our finance
rate for the next
um 50 years at a low level
interest rate uh hedging in the next 10
years is keeping that down we're
on a profile which is going down we've
still got quite
high there's some of our hedging that
we've got on our box is still quite high
we can't close it out because it would
cost us quite a fortune so we just leave
it there
and it just closes itself out over time
but yes
we're on a slope which is seeing a
decreasing rate at the moment
and yes it will start rising again in
the future but the key is that you
manage that risk with
hedging and yes if it gets up to 22
again i don't think anyone's going to be
able to manage uh
that type of interest and that's we
can't hedge up to 25 years can we
no no it would cause it would if you got
interest rates of 22 like you've seen in
the late 80s
uh we'd have to put rates up you can't
sustain it
cow's very concerned probably
jim just around the local government
sector and the explanation we just gave
up on three waters and i realized the
uncertainty around that but
that's been discussed in forums i've
been at um
certainly with with other councils and
uh
and that did level have we had um
if questioned on that and that's one of
the reasons that we're going to this
policy or
looking at going this policy if question
on that do you
do you think this council said
sufficient sufficient discussions
that are documented previous by the head
room
um and the fact that we've talked about
uh
taking our lanes loans out over longer
periods for those do you think we would
have
significant uh sorry enough information
that we've discussed
that before the question has been raised
around three waters to defend our
position i think
this decision can be made independent of
the three waters review i just put that
in as a little additional
uh flavor of uncertainty over the next
two or three years you know i
i if i felt that this wasn't
the right long-term thing to do for the
council or wasn't
a sustainable view then
then i'd then i'd certainly tell you
that the reason
we had 25 years initially and
this goes back nearly 20 years jeff and
i have been working on our financial
strategy together is through the early
times
of our six ltps that we've put together
we you know to be fair we didn't have a
high degree of confidence in our
asset management planning and our
renewal
program and our expectations for growth
and we continue to adopt a reasonably
conservative approach in regards to debt
repayment which was get it off the
books as quickly as we can because we're
not quite sure what's coming
i i'm certainly over the last
uh half a dozen years in particular
host earthquakes and with the work that
our team have done
on our infrastructure modeling
and you can see that in jeff's capex
program that's
you know you take away the the known
peaks the underlying programs looking
reasonably
stable based on good
engineering advice so got a lot more
confidence about
the the renewal profile and shape of our
future expenditure and therefore some
higher level of confidence
that we can be less aggressive
and not unduly impact our overall
financial position or compromise the
council
if i thought that was the case i
certainly wouldn't be
supporting this approach but i but i
think i think this can be reasonably
sustained by the council
council meetings followed by council
stuart in
casablanca thank you um yeah when i
when i was reading this i i did think
with the three waters that that was
possibly what you were
going for in the event that we
maintain these long life assets um
the interest rates do go up are we able
to
if if we deem it to be a better idea are
we able to actually revert to
a faster payoff rate
yes you can yeah
that allows us to hedge our bets um
no i had another question and it's gone
i can't beat you
thank you okay come back to you in a
minute
cats cats stewart thank you i got quite
excited about this
when i read the first page and then i
turned because i immediately thought of
earthquake loans and the multi-use
stadium and then i flipped the page and
got a bit depressed but um can can you
explain
why um
why this can't apply to those two um
elements i know you've got it because of
the way the loans
are structured can you just you can
you take voting for instance a lot of
the roading uh
life of the roading the reseals and then
it's less than it's some of us
around that less than 25 years actually
what you could do with the roading is
you could take
the the covets the culverts and the
bridges out of that and you could treat
that
acid as a separate category and do that
over a longer period
so you you get the same sort of weighted
average approach
and that's what we just need to model
just it's a little bit more complicated
um i haven't worked with um joanne to go
through that yet
uh some of the the same applies with
some of their green space
playground equipment and stuff like that
you could you could do the same thing
for that
multi-court stadium we've already made
that decision to
put the depreciation reserve into that
in the first
25 years until the lines repaid off and
then
accumulate the funds after that
use your user might create this and
alter that
and i mean that same argument is the
earthquake loan
so i mean they come up for renewal
in within that 25-year period so why
can't you
get from there yes the intention is to
come back
to the council with um with
the other assets that we own and see
whether that can be applied to them as
well
yep yeah
thank you you've rethought your question
so
um so if we we change
to um that average weighted life of the
assets being
over um 50 years does the
depreciation rate still stay the same so
we're still putting
the same amount yeah so some of our
younger suppliers we have a quite a low
funded depreciation rate because they'll
build that so they'll be
build that kitty up over a longer period
and the investment will kick in whereas
a more
an older supply you'll be funding um
you know 80 percent to 90 percent of
that
true depreciation cost thank you
just two questions from me the one of
the
reasons why you're confident that this
is a good strategy
would it be for you to say that is it
correct you're
confident in the asset base we've got
following the earthquake renewals
that's one of them i think the other one
is as well you're growing
as a council when we keep on sustaining
two percent plus growth
you're actually building your um not
just your asset base but your
ratepayer base and it can sustain it so
your actual
loan can actually keep just creeping the
same
and still have the same type of ratio
but you can see
from some of those tables they showed
there it's it's going from 187 down to
which means we're actually even under
this policy we've actually got
strengthening our position so that gives
you confidence
it gives me confidence as well that
we're in the right
framework the other thing which uh we do
differently to a lot of councils and
you know what new zealand have commented
on it off
the auto general is that the way we are
to putting away depreciation funding for
future replacement
um very prudently they think
and you know really good quite a good
strong position
so we were taking no the three words
we're taking all of us
i would be quite confident that i'd be
pretty happy for our position
and you're confident that this will not
affect our
center and pause rating
uh we've had a preliminary meeting with
standard poor's
uh in the new year they haven't
indicated
that it's uh going to change we've put
that
proposal that it could be an option that
the council have to consider
the the main ratios they use
were well within the uh maintaining that
double a
they have said that there's still quite
a high capital
program there that's the one that
concerns them but
once again i've sent them the
current proposed you know
statements that the plan and the
statements that surround that
and you know
i'm never ever confident with the
numbers until you see them but
i'm fairly more confident not
that we'd maintain a double a stable
jeremy you've got to remember the world
economy is quite
bad at the moment and they have said to
us that
there's been more degradings in
australia than what they have been
pointless and um so that's something to
be wary of
and another lockdown and whatever that
does to the sovereign
uh will affect us as well they did
express confidence in new zealand
they yes yeah more positives than new
zealand and
in australia council edmond
ah thanks jeff two questions firstly
do the rate projects projections that
you've given us
earlier apply to the
three waters assets only having
their loan term extended or have you
factored in
other assets for a long lifetime
it's question one yeah just the three
waters at this stage
until i um have the modeling to put in
front of the council to
recommend anything further for the other
assets
um you know because of roading has such
as
extensive network and it's just really
the culverts and bridges i need to
really have a good look at those numbers
to see what the weighted
the what it looks like the modelling and
it's the same with the green space
as yet so i want to have a good look at
those as well well just following on
from that secondly if the policy is
approved
um in recommendation d it notes that you
will be looking at these other assets
um would that come to the council on a
case-by-case basis
if we approve the policy as recommended
uh yes sir i wouldn't be looking at
coming back in the current
year it would be later on after this
plan with my recommendation
you take land purchases for instance you
could do the same thing with land if you
to categorize it
and leave the other assets out so you
could do that
but you just be careful that like with
roading
they have acid reseals and stuff like
that that's less
much less than 25 years so i
just want to really do their modelling
first much easier to do with the three
waters
okay thank you um there's a
recommendation you're prepared to move
council right consumers per the order
paper and
seconded by uh council award who is to
speak
well they've been great discussion
around it really i mean we've uh
right back in earthquake times we've
talked about our assets lasting 80 90
sometimes 100 years you know with the
improvement of
quality products that are being used so
um
it makes sense to me that they're
inter-generational when they're when
they're
paid for and um not only that
depreciation that comes on
on on top of that i think this is
actually quite a prudent thing to do
and i think you'll see most councils
doing it i mean i get the step where
we're starting
and that was the reason for my question
to
mr palmer i don't want to be questioned
by the government saying we've only
taken this particular piece
because we're doing this and that's
going to come across the board not just
to us as a
as a council but i think to all councils
so i just want to make sure that our
we actually have the the the back
discussions that we've had long before
the three waters uh suggestions of
uh going to other identities actually
came up because
i can clearly remember these and
certainly when jeff
came with the new um depreciation uh
model to us that we discussed nice life
of assets and that we in the future may
be able to fund them over longer times
and and such like so we've had those and
that was i knew the answer to the
question it was just
one of those um one of those things that
i just wanted you know everybody to hear
that we're that we are on the right side
of that fence and i do believe we are
this is this is a an important thing to
do
and i think going forward it will be
very beneficial and certainly when we
model all those other
assets which i get will be a bit of a
complicated exercise in some places but
others will become
very apparent and very easy to do i mean
it would be very few buildings that we
own
that we would be replacing under 50
years
unless there are disasters so i mean
there's certainly things that we need to
be looking at to see that we have the
right
loan periods and depreciation periods on
so i
absolutely support this thank you
councilwood thank you um
yes i thoroughly approve of this
it um given that a lot of our
infrastructure is fairly new since the
earthquakes
um and as in the change of
how how things are made up today they're
made to last a lot longer and i think it
makes a lot of sense
to push out so that
there is relief to people today and that
the
repayment is spread over the people that
are using it in the future so
makes a lot of sense and it's very is a
very prudent thing to do and i look
forward to
uh further enhancing the uh roading and
other
assets that we might have in the same
way
okay councillor williams
yeah well it looks rosy um
the world is full of calamities and um
we're just talking about farmers risks
and problems that could come into the
scenario um
jeff was just talking about their growth
structure there helping this
well i understood we're going to be
running out of land soon for growth
and it might going to be stopping and
um so we haven't thought about
the climate change we don't know what's
happening there
we don't know whether covet's going to
come back into we don't know when the
alpine float's going to happen
we don't know we may have to end up
still keeping water
the water standards are going to rise
our sewer system
is going to have to be upgraded for the
um
about the um out to sea or ocean out for
whatever we have to do
we've got to think of all those things
nothing in my lifetime is really
well probably in the last 20 years has
been
standard it's all been calamity after
calamity
and this actually is basically implying
there's going to be no more
major calamities where there there are
going to be some more so
i don't think we can address thinking
our
children and grandchildren and great
great friends we're going to have more
money than what we've got to
pay our debts at the moment i think it's
probably possibly going to be the
opposite
so i think we can look after our future
and if we want something we pay for it
now
okay so i have um casa barnett stewart
in redmond's council
well i want to congratulate staff on on
being innovative and looking at ways
we asked our staff to look at ways that
they could lower rates
and this is lowering rates um it's but
it's also managing our finances very
very prudently
and it's in line with other councils
around the country so i really want to
congratulate the financial staff for
finding this option
and i'm quite excited that they're going
to look at other options
which are sensible when you take a
mortgage on a house you may never pay it
back
you sell the asset to pay back the
mortgage so that's a totally normal
situation
and yes if situations change we can
change the policy
that's what happens but i don't think we
should be looking at everything as if
it's going to crash tomorrow
we've got to look positively towards the
future and if something changes we then
change our financial policy
and i'm totally and utterly confident
that we're in an excellent financial
place
considering the earthquakes considering
the other financial
issues that we've had over the past 10
years
i'm absolutely confident that this has
been managed in an
excellent way and that's shown by our
excellence rating and local government
as well and the confidence
that our community has in us so thank
you very much for this
bringing this report to us i'm totally
in support and um
if you can find other ways to lower
rates i'm all for it
thank you uh councillor stewart thank
you
certainly like to endorse my colleague
councillor barnett's
comments just then i totally agree
i also am really enthused about applying
this view across other of our
assets and as jeff's indicated
certainly the the the big
debts of um the earthquake loan
and the multi-court stadium uh
when that um when they come
the existing loans come up for renewal
extending
them out because most of the assets that
have been replaced through the
earthquake loan are
long life and certainly we would
confidently expect the maori court
stadium to last more than 25 years
but um i'm i'm attracted
particularly to because as other
colleagues have said
pc7 and we'll get the first hint of that
next week when the officer's response
to the questions raised at the panel
publicised they are going to hit our
farming sector and the thing that
makes this so very attractive is that
as stated it puts money directly in the
hand of the people who need it
our farming sector particularly right
now
and progressively over the next 10 years
so
that alone and as i said the philosophy
associated
with this is i embrace it totally but
this
delivers money back into the hands of
rate payers and if we're talking
seriously about
helping our community and the sectors of
the community that really will
need help in the next short to medium
term
this actually does it so um
certainly fully endorse it thank you
council event thank you mr mayor when i
first saw this i was quite dubious
because my traditional background is
that the sooner you pay debt off
the better you are because you save a
lot over the term of the loan
however i have changed
my mind to a degree simply because this
record recommendation is focused on the
three waters
assets and there is uncertainty with
those
and uh jim
has echoed my thoughts in that area
so i'm prepared to support this
recommendation on the basis that at the
moment
it is applying to the three waters
assets
and that other assets will be looked at
on a case-by-case basis
because it may it may not be a size of
one size fits all
and we don't want to get too tricky and
uh try and be too smart but
um jeff has been innovative because i
think in one of your responses geoff you
indicated only two other councils were
doing this
so if that is the case we're we're right
out in front so
i i think that's good position for us so
having said that
i'm i'm delighted now to support the
motion
the recommendation thank you council
meetings
um yes jeff i i think this is a really
great
tool for us to have in our arsenal it
does address
intergenerational equity and whilst
it is most of our um you know
first thing that we think of is to
reduce debt as quickly as possible
that's our personal debt that we will
personally have to pay off whereas these
things are over assets that belong to
all of us and and over a long period of
time so i completely understand that
um and i'm sure that you you know i
wouldn't like to see us
necessarily apply this to a whole lot of
things
but i am because of course i can quickly
see a bow wave of of
50 years
amortizations to be built up over that
time
but i am sure that you will be prudent
and not
not put us in that position you you have
an excellent track record in managing
these things in the past and i think
that this is a great idea particularly
with that class of assets
and i'm happy to support it thank you
i'm not going to prolong it but just to
say i support it as well i think it's
very prudent
financial management and that has been
the hallmark of both yourself and jim's
leadership and the finance team and
our broader team so thanks jeff for
bringing this forward and
carries my support right by country just
very very quickly just to
um you know i mean i've sat through that
the last 10-year plan and we had
people submit to us about
intergenerational costs
and have actually come to this council
before us have said
we don't want to pay for people that are
coming into this district
um whether it be the youngsters or
whether it be other youngsters they need
to pay their own way
and and and it's come through very
strong and ltp
particularly lgp
discussions and the other thing is that
councillor williams is
100 right we do not know what we do not
know
okay with with that i'm going to put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye contrary
declare that so european contrary and
give us your vote recorded
so i declare that kerry
right now it's time for uh morning tea
so if we
come back at 10 to 11
denise i assume you're here for an item
to do with 4.2
so welcome
after morning tea it's
that'll be considered early in the pace
so it's one of the first reports up here
so
just to let you know that you're welcome
to join us for morning tea as well if
you'd like to
cheers so we'll see you all at 10 to 11.
thank you
you